out of the blue this is the typical
patriot move nobody thought the patriots
were interested they had plenty of
opportunities to show interest all the
patriots aren't interested all the
patriots are fine uh with the guys they
have and then all of a sudden cam newton
is a patriot and everybody's like man
that makes sense we should have seen
that one coming chris what was your
first thought when you saw cam newton
headed to new england like
shock but then i was like well why am i
shocked like what i mean this is it's
just so new england yeah oh yeah oh yeah
we'll just get a guy that's you know
what i think is one of the 10 best
quarterbacks in football for a million
dollars and add them to our team it's
just like they waited everybody out they
thought i'm sure they did their research
called talked to all the right people
i mean knowing new england i wouldn't be
shocked that they had him followed
really to really watch him and see
what's going on and see what he looks
like in workouts i mean i wouldn't be
shocked by any of it
but you know of course i'm intrigued yes
i mean cam newton's a special talent and
he is you know a guy that i think new
england they could have a tremendous
boom factor here yeah i think it's one
of those things i look at and go like
it's either going to be like
new england in the afc championship game
or he won't win the starting job and
jared said and we'll beat him out you
know jared sillam's not going to lay
down here i know that he's got talent
they like him i think what they just
said is hey we can keep this guy for a
few more years and there's this other
guy that's a proven commodity that like
can take over games by himself and yeah
he's been hurt but let's try him out
because we still got this guy stidham in
our back pocket for as long as we want
so we're in a no wins or no lose
situation here really um but you know i
think uh this has a chance to be special
but i'm not 100 sold on that it will be
because it's going to be tough in this
year and that offense as i've told you
before is the toughest offense to learn
in all of football
two factors well actually let me give
you three factors now that you've
mentioned the offense i'm going to start
with the offense yeah
i don't necessarily think that he's
going to be learning the patriots
offense i think the offense is going to
adapt to yeah
the guy who drafted tim tebow back in
2010 created an offense that later was
used when tebow was the starter after
mcdaniels was fired because it all fell
apart and remember when jacoby played
mike they ran kind of that same type of
offense too when he had to come in for
jimmy garoppolo the year brady was
suspended sorry i just wanted to throw
that in there you're fine yeah but
they're not going to take they're not
going to take the square peg and cram it
into the round hole they're going to
have an offensive cam newton is able to
run if he can win the job number two is
he healthy that's going to be the key
more than anything else he passed the
physical
they they kind of took a leap of faith
in doing the deal when the agents
represented the patriots that cam newton
is good to go but if he's healthy then
we get maybe cam newton of 2015 who
knows and then the key ultimately is
going to be and this is a point that
peter king made earlier josh mcdaniels
has never been in cam newton's presence
we don't know if they're going to get
along we don't know what kind of a
relationship they're going to have we
don't know whether or not that aspect of
it will work now we think it will work
because of the way the patriots played
this they allowed circumstances to beat
cam newton down to the point where he
was ready to take anything and when you
look at the contract he took with a base
of 1.05 million
and a high end of seven and a half
million we broke down the incentives
he has to have essentially league mvp
super bowl mvp type season to get the
7.5 million and if that happens it'll be
the greatest investment in the history
of sports because they will have won the
super bowl before he gets 7.5 million
um
you know look it's he's he's motivated
yeah he's determined and even if year
two or year three with josh mcdaniels
wouldn't work i think year one's gonna
work because they're getting cam newton
with the absolute perfect mindset to
come in and do everything that's asked
of him and and prove everyone wrong that
looked the other way when cam newton
became available yeah no i mean
i agree with just about everything you
said there and you know back to the
playbook stuff you know i mean you're
right you know this is kind of what i
said there on the podcast they're gonna
formulate the offense around him no
doubt and you know people got to realize
these plays you know they're already in
new england the the cam newton type
plays are already in the new england
playbook now with tom brady a quarter
brady doesn't use it well yeah
they might have been at page 180 on the
playbook when he was a quarterback now
they'll bump him up 100 pages but
all of this is there and then nobody in
the history of football is better at
building off of what you do good and
then figuring out the formula listen and
my one of my big things i said and my
first reaction to this whole thing was i
truly think this team is built
to play
cam newton football
more than it is to play let's just say
tom brady football when i say that i
mean spread the field out throw the ball
quick decisions you know the things
we've seen brady dissect people with
forever they're not really made for that
right now but running the ball
guys like mohammed sunu julian edelman
nikhil harry who have like special skill
sets where you can run them they can
throw it you can have a lot of movement
and things like that within your offense
uh i think there's a lot of potential
here and i think new england you know
like i said i i'm betting on boom i
really am i'm with you there i'm betting
on boom uh i just a little bit of a bust
factor for me
remember when we were counting down the
quarterbacks from 40 up to number one
somewhere in the high teens there was a
line of demarcation between the guys who
are very adept at running the play
that's called and the guys who if the
play that's called goes to hell in a
handbasket can make something happen
newton was on the right side of that so
this is an element that the patriots
have not had with tom brady it's
pre-snap reads decisions made quickly
ball gets out quickly if the play begins
to fall apart it's bail out before you
get blown up cam newton is going to be
able to extend and improvise and develop
and that's what we've seen the patriots
struggle with when they face a guy like
cam newton and by the way get your pft
bingo cards ready cam newton 2-0 all the
time against bill belichick
in hindsight why look i know why it took
so long it took so long because they
knew they knew they could get him on
better terms if they waited exactly one
of the issues that came up last week
they resolved long-standing grievances
with antonio brown and aaron hernandez's
estate and creates seven million in cap
space yeah right after they get cam
newton's ink dry on the contract after
they told him sorry this is all we have
they get seven million in fresh cap
dollars that he could have said i want
those this is why the patriots have six
super bowl trophies they know how to
hatch a plan they know how to implement
a plan they know how to keep their
mouths shut and they get the guy if
other teams knew what bill belichick was
thinking of doing somebody else would
have jumped on cam newton before
belichick could have gotten him yeah no
i i mean yes and hey they had a
situation
where at the quarterback situation i
think it was one of the easier ones to
accept a cam newton in on the team too
right mike i think that's the other
thing and i agree with everything you
said there uh but they have a guy that
at least in the locker room people like
and think has potential but he's not
like oh this is our starter and then oh
crap cam newton's crapping all over them
every day in practice and now you devise
the locker room you know this would be
one of those things where i think the
team can accept it pretty quick once
they see cam newton out there and he
knows the offense they're going to be
like whoa okay we got a stud here we go
and they're gonna be completely fine
with him being the starting quarterback
with steadm being unproven to this point
all those guys who were praising jared
stidham's potential quickly pivoted to
praise cam newton's performance and it
will not be a schism in the new england
locker room when cam newton finally
shows up
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports